un tas de cendres quelques poutres
calcinées
c'est tout ce qu'il reste de la maison
en quelques minutes ce couple et leurs
trois enfants ont tout perdu dans
l'incendié qui a ravagé leur pavillon
mais il s'estime déjà heureux d'être
encore là même si on a tout perdu on est
encore vivants c'est surtout vraiment
c'est le principal parce que j'ai mes
trois enfants ma femme mon épouse qui
est au sain et sauf
énormément de problème par contre on a
au niveau administratif mais on a
énormément de soutien
il habitait ici depuis - donnant leur
maison était neuf
ces photos ont à peine quelques mois et
nous la montre avant l' incendie
le couple et les trois enfants sont
depuis relogés dans leur famille ils ont
pu compter sur un bel élan de solidarité
une cagnotte en ligne a été mise en
place et toute la commune se mobilise en
mairie les habitants se succèdent pour
venir en aide à la famille sinistrée
une urne a été déposée pour accueillir
les dons les habitants d'un aussi
spontanément proposé vaisselle meubles
jouets et l'autre soit solidaire comme
ça il faut être vraiment le main dans la
main et se soutenir
nous sommes un petit village et il faut
il faut s'entraider
vous vous rendez compte ils ils ont 40
ans tous les deux ils ont trois enfants
il était dans une maison pleine de
bonheur plein de et là plus rien mais
plus rien pas en pyjama la famille
cherche toujours son chien ce jeune
border collie qui se serait enfuie la
nuit de l'incendié
le couple attend désormais le passage
des experts pu le verdict des assureurs
il espère à terme pouvoir en construire
la maison au même endroit